So, we made these three histograms, and let's take a
closer look at them. We have one for females, one
for males, and one for NA. NA stands for Not
Applicable. And the third histogram we just created contains users who
are not labeled as male or female. This is how
R handles missing values. Missing values take on a value
of NA. Let's try creating our histogram for friend counts
split by gender one more time. But this time we'll take
a subset of our data and ignore the observations where the
gender is an a. To do that, I'm going to subset our data.
I can use the Subset command. And use a condition for the
second parameter. The first parameter is just the data set. Here I'm
using the is dot NA function with a bang. This removes
any rows that have NA for the gender variable. So if I
run this code this time I shouldn't see the NA and fixing
a small typo I can see I have my two histograms for
females and males. Now I do want to point out there's
another way that we could have subset the data. If,
instead, I use the na.omit function, I would remove any
observations that have NA in them, not necessarily just for gender.
You want to be careful when using the na.omit wrapper since
we might end up ignoring some users that are labeled as
male or female But, they might have different variables that
do have NA values. Say for like friend_count or something else.